παρεμβάσεις πραγματικές το ναπω αδιακρίτως μιώνο τοφύπια στο τάδιο προϊών σωματών εσωματο ατοτέλιως είναι σωμάδο
θα δομε στην διμή ήπως οι σωστή κατεύθυσε στοχευμένοι έχω εφοδιαστική να λυσίδα έρκεται με
αυτό των τρόπο ων το πρϊών εμπλέκουνται είκοση επιχειρήσεις για να αρτή να προϊνο στην
κύπρο τι μπορώ να κάμομεκείνη τραφορολογικά μια άλλη προσεγγιση για αναβελτειόσο το κόστος σίνης της
αλυσίδας επιτροπία ανταγωνισμούπο εναι υπιτροπε να ς έχουμε ίκοσι τομίς οι οποίοι αγκίζουν το ισόδη
μα σου μέσα στο σπίτισούν ξέρουμε ότι οι ζούμες σε μια μικρίν οικονομία με μικρόν
ανταγωνισμό που είναι κλαδικές έρεύνες γιατί ενταμμε ε δηλαδίκές έρευνεται να καταλάβουμε πρόσεξε κλαδικαίρευνα εκαιη
ερκεται να πει κααπάτίνεσ ανιανταγωνιστική συμπερήφορά κιτά λιπάικλαδικαίρευ να ερκέτας ι αναλίει την ανταγωνιστική συμπεριφορά
να καταλάβουμε πο ε το πρόβλημα ξερά θα θελαπάντι εν ανάλλων πράγμα στασισοκομματικάμιχαλημο το ότι
συνεχώς λέτε είμασε ν αντιπολύτευση αλλά δημοσιεύματα θέλουν στελέγχει του κόμματος κάποιες φορές παλιάστε λέχει
του κόμματος που ίσως να στηρίζεση του πάνωτους σε προπλογική στην προεκλοεκή που έρκεται για
το κοσέξη ότι τρον μαζί με τον πρόεδρον της δηποκρατίας και υπουργούς της κυβέρνησης και
ίναι ενταει να σταματήσουμε το μόσμο να έχισχέ ενα χι σχέσεις τηδισημένη τουτόε γι αυτός
θέροτα στην αρχη υπάρχει κρίση τα αυτόνα το συμεριμο διαδήυπαρα όχιι κρατόπαδα υπάρχου καιταξεο κδημοκρακός
τη αγερμός βγήκε το ξέρουμε όλι το βλέπουμε όλοι το καταλάβαμε όλοι ότι η ευγεή
και πό μια δύσκολη εμπέριοδον τοκοστία με με μιαηταν ι οποία